موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم شيعه اهالي الجنين
بالضفه الغربيه جثامين اربعه شهداء سقطوا
امس برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وسط
المدينه ومن بينهم قائدان عسكريان في
حركته حماس والجهاد الاسلامي اغتالتهما
وحده اسرائيليه خاصه
النار على جنود الاحتلال في الاشهر
الماضيه وقد اعتبرت سلطه الفلسطينيه ان
العمليه تهدف لتفجير الاوضاع بينما توعدت
الفصائل اسرائيل بالرد
وفي تعليقه على تطورات في الضفه الغربيه
قال الجنرال مايكل كوريلا قائد القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه قال ان ظروف تفاقم الوضع
فيها قائمه ولا احد يعلم الشراره التي قد
تؤدي لصراع اوسع نقل شبكه تي ان عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان البنتاغون يجري
تقييما لمسارات المسيرات الامريكيه في
اجواء البحر الاسود ويبحث طرقا بديله
لتفادي المقاتلات الروسيه في شبه جزيره
القرم وتجنب تصعيد مع روسيا وذكر
المسؤولون ان البنتاغون يدرس الاعتماد على
الاقمار الصناعيه لجمع المعلومات في البحر
الاسود بديلا للمسيرات اعتقلت اجهزه الامن
الفرنسيه 217 شخصا خلال احتجاجات الليليه
على اقرار الرئيس الفرنسي
قانون رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما من دون
تصويت النواب وقالت وسائل اعلام فرنسيه ان
الشرطه تفرقت بالقوه مظاهرات في ساحه
الكونكورد وسط باريس وان اداره الاطفاء
اخمدت عده حرائق وشهدت مدن بينها مارسيليا
واران اعمال عنف احتجاج اعمال عنف في
الاحتجاجات ايضا
واعلنت زعيمه اقصى اليمين في فرنسا ماريلو
بان انها ستقدم اقتراحا بسحب الثقه من
الحكومه بعد قرار الرئيس ايمانويل
المصادقه على اصلاح نظام التقاعد من دون
تصويت في الجمعيه الوطنيه واكدت والتي
تقود نواب حزب التجمع الوطني ان القرار
فشل ذريع للرئيس ماكرون ورئيسه وزراء
اليزابيث بورن واضافت ان الاخيره لا يمكن
ان تبقى في منصبها
وصفت الخارجيه الاثيوبيات تصريحات
المنسوبه الى وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري بغير المسؤوله وقالت انها تحمل
تهديدا لاثيوبيا بشان سد النهضه وجددت
الدعوه الى حل بشان السد عبر التفاوض
واكدت التزامها بتسويه في صالح الجميع
وكان وزير الخارجيه المصري قد تحدث عن
جمود تشهد المفاوضات مع اثيوبيا معتبرا
مساله السد اولويه وجوديه تمس حياه الشعب
المصري وقال ان كل الخيارات مفتوحه
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء